I receive some questions recently that
asked that some proofs by contradiction
and I really like proof a contradiction
it's a really clever sort of thing even
though it's not taught very much in the
syllabus that I have to teach my classes
but I figure you know even though it's
really cool method a lot of people don't
know about it so before I answer the
actual questions that I've been given
let me just um set out what's the
difference between the normal way that
we prove things which is often called
just direct proof and and proof by
contradiction which is often called
indirect proof for reasons you'll see in
a second how does direct proof work well
suppose for each of them really you have
some statement let's call it statement a
that says something like oh I don't know
root two is irrational that's a
statement okay and there's a very famous
proof for the irrationality of root two
now statement a we want to prove that
how would you go about doing it as a
direct proof well what you would do is
you'd start from you know things that
you know so is there any known data or
definitions you know things like what is
a written irrational number or rational
number you start from that okay and then
what you want to do is think about well
okay what kinds of valid mathematical
processes or all logic can you use to
manipulate what you know like your your
data or your definitions and change it
so that you arrive at your the statement
that you want to statement a so it's
kind of three steps here you start from
what you already can assume to be true
or things that are accepted as true
axioms definitions etc you do some stuff
to it you manipulate it until you get to
what you want okay that's a direct proof
that's what mostly used to it has an
indirect proof work or proof by
contradiction well instead of starting
from things that everyone agrees on it's
that's a bit backwards because what you
do is you take your desired statement
statement a okay and you assume that
it's false okay
so right from the get-go you're saying
well let's just imagine
what if it were not true so assume that
not a is true now after you assume that
is true you you take there some logic so
for instance in this case you'd say well
suppose root two were actually rational
so I'm assuming that statement a is
false you do the same thing you apply
some mathematical processes or some
logic right you manipulate it and then
now here's why it's called a proof by
contradiction you arrive at something
which is well as the name suggests
contradictory something which clearly
cannot make sense or you know flatly is
the opposite of what you actually
assumed in the original okay so I what
you've got is now a contradiction
something which must be false so if you
arrive a contradiction just by doing
totally valid stuff this must be the
problem the problem must be where you
began right so what you would do is that
you would recognize that a contradiction
here implies this assumption to be wrong
so therefore you would conclude that
since the assumption is wrong which is
that a desire statement is false that
you conclude that the desired statement
must be true which is not so hard but it
is a bit of a rounder route roundabout
way to do things which is why it's often
called a indirect proof okay now the
question that I actually got asked to
prove one of the questions that I got
asked to prove by contradiction or we're
required to prove is that there is no
smallest rational or positive rational
number hmm now this is interesting you
can see why it might be approached by a
proof by contradiction because it's like
well where would you even begin if you
were to do a direct proof like what what
no data or definitions would be a good
starting point okay so what we're going
to do is think about what would happen
this is step one you know what would
happen if this were false okay so here's
my proof okay and it's going to be
improved by contradiction I'll start off
by saying well let's assume
that there is a smallest possible
smallest positive rational number okay
so if there is a number I should be able
to give it a name so I'm going to call
it epsilon okay epsilon is kind of a
traditional number for traditional name
for mathematicians when they want to
talk about small numbers okay so if
epsilon is the smallest positive
rational number I can say things like
well epsilon must be greater than zero
okay and I can also say that epsilon
must be equal to and I'm going to
introduce some more letters here P on Q
where P and Q are integers okay now what
am I doing here
I've started with my my assumption which
is actually wrong right now what I mean
what am i doing
I'm applying my valid mathematical
processes and logic now what's this line
about P and Q are integers and what I've
introduced is a fraction or a ratio this
is the definition of a rational number
okay so number one I've said it's
positive number two I've said it's
rational okay right now let's apply some
more logic to this if this is a rational
number right I should be able to just
divide by two
right so if I divide both sides by two
I'm going to get P on to Q ah but this
leads to a problem because since I've
already said that Q is an integer right
if Q is an integer therefore if I double
Q that should still be an integer right
you know take an integer you like three
four five six 200 whatever if you double
it it stays an integer it doesn't become
you know a fraction or anything like
that
so therefore this this number here that
I've got Epsilon on - it's also a
rational number because it's a ratio a
fraction with an integer on the top and
in easier on the bottom okay so I can
say therefore
epsilon on 2 is rational now can can you
see the public you see the contradiction
now since epsilon 2 is rational right
but epsilon is greater than zero that
means epsilon two must be smaller than
epsilon the number I started with okay
but that's a contradiction because I
said that epsilon must be the smallest
possible rational number positive
rational number that's where I started
but now just by doing some simple math
I've come up with a new one right I've
come up with a new smallest positive
rational number okay so this is a
contradiction therefore my assumption at
the beginning that there is a smallest
positive rational number it must have
been true you know epsilon cannot exist
you know it's at the same time it's the
smallest positive rational number and is
also one smaller than okay
so therefore I can now come all the full
circle right I can say well there
mustn't be a smallest positive and you
can write it like this if you like
positive rational number okay so that's
a proof by contradiction